Let's look at the solution to our
consistency quiz where we have coherent
memory but an out-of-order pair of
cores, where branches are predicted,
stores are still done strictly
in program order, but
loads can be reordered and
these two variables start at zero.
What the programmer is kind of expecting
to happen is that I put put some values
in some data, then I set a flag,
and the other core waits for
that flag to be set so that it can
print the data that I produced.
In program order, the only thing that
can really happen, is that we print 15.
In the execution order,
that can also happen.
If this core gets to this part
before we even start checking,
we might compute 15 in the data,
set flag to one, core one,
loops here, sees that the flag is one,
exits, brings 15.
So, clearly 15 is possible.
But the question is can
we get anything else?
These are done strictly in order so
if anything else does get printed, it's
not going to be because this core did
the data right after the flag was set.
The flag actually gets set after
the rights are complete but
here's what can happen.
This loop here amounts to reading
the flag, testing if it's zero,
and then branching based on that.
This processor can easily predict
this branch in a way that says
we exit before it even gets
to check what the flag was.
So at that point we will be here and
we will fetch the data to be printed.
The data at that point might be zero.
So what we do is we predict it goes out
and we fetch the data at this point.
So it's kind of step one predict,
and leave loop.
Step two, read the data, and
it's zero at this point.
Then let's say core 2 finishes this, and
at that point out-of-order
processor does this load, remember,
these are load,
they can be re-ordered, if we do this,
we see that the flag at this point
is one so prediction was correct.
And at this point,
we can print the data that we found.
In this case, we will print zero.
A similar outcome is possible for
data = 10, simply by moving this here.
So, we can also print ten
if access number two,
which reads the data after the
prediction of the branch happens here.
And finally we could get 15 and
the data if we get it here, but
we already knew we could get 15.
Note that it's not possible
to get five or anything else.
And the reason is that these writes on
the same core will happen in program
order.
It's incorrect for
a core to somehow read zero here.
because the only way we read data here,
is if it was already written here.
On the same core,
we have to obey the program order.
That was never in question.
So the data when it's
read here has to be 10.
We can only increment it by 5 to 15,
we cannot read 0 here.
So that's why it's possible
only to get 0, 10, or 15.
So basically, the real problem is
that somehow, although we thought
we are waiting for the flag to be set
before we access the data, in reality we
managed to access the data at kind of
any point before the flag was set.
And coherence, again,
didn't prevent this.
What we need is consistency.